hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast drug targeting for
inflammatory breast cancer presented by
dr. Kevin Williams associate professor
biomanufacturing Research Institute and
technology Enterprise North Carolina
Central University
I am excited catears of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
Reed alighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
Reed's lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to attain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Williams I will
now turn the presentation over to him
thanks to Xavier so just to give a
little bit of background on our
institution during North Carolina
Central University ruin HBCU were part
of the UNC system we have a strong
commitment to health disparities
research and we house two signature
institutes I'm a member of the bright
and one of our main missions is to
educate students to be ready to work in
the pharmaceutical industry so a quick
overview of my seminar I'm going to talk
about targeting IBC through two
mechanisms the first is therapeutic
resistance and the second is the
hedgehog pathway so a little bit of
background on inflammatory breast cancer
I'm not sure many people really heard
about IBC but it's a unique understudied
and very lethal subtype accounts for
about six percent of all breast cancers
but 15 percent of breast cancer deaths
and there's a low survival rate of only
34 percent but this is eighty-seven
percent over five years for compared to
non IBC breast cancers penomet challenge
is IBC presents a late stage stage three
or four diagnosis there's no solid tumor
so it's not typically detected by
mammogram hence the new lump required so
no luck required is part of the
education campaign by one of our other
groups the inflammatory breast cancer
Research Foundation so there they
advocate for IBC IBC incidence is also
higher in younger patients and in women
of African descent the presence of
tumour emboli is a hallmark and again
another challenge is there's a lack of
preclinical models and clinical samples
so that's always a challenge along the
right there I've got images of a patient
with IPC and the lone learner right is
an image of a tumor in Malaya from a
clinical sample a little bit more about
IBC on the clinical pathology so
clinically there's a rapid onset of skin
changes with progression to stage 3b or
for a within six months so rapid onset
is an issue the breast often looks
swollen red or inflamed or on the right
here has its pod Orange physical
appearance so there was a very
characteristics of IBC for the pathology
as I said one of the hallmarks of IBC is
the presence of dermal lymphatic
invasion by hyper proliferative clusters
of highly invasive tumor emboli so those
are all hallmarks of IBP
IBC for diagnosis current therapeutic
strategy strategies for IBC multimodal
therapy so near adjuvant chemo followed
by mastectomy and chest radiation
for patients who have metastatic stage 4
ABC if their cancer is hormone
receptor-positive they can have hormone
therapy if their cancer it's her2
positive they can have targeted therapy
with drugs that target her too so for
example the tyrosine kinase inhibitor
patent if that hits per one and two is
one of the few treatment options for ABC
but resistance to that drug is seen in
the clinic so again another challenge
for what we're working on so alongside
dr. Gayatri Devi from Duke University
which is about five miles up the road
from our campus and we've been working
over probably the past decade on
building a program to identify effective
therapies for inflammatory breast cancer
so we have a number of girls we have a
number of publications and it's we'll
talk a little bit about a couple of
those another thing we have a big focus
on is disparities in breast cancer so
again african-american women are
typically diagnosed with breast cancer
at the early stage at a early age at a
later stage
there's so many disparities that persist
that may involve genetics biological
factors breast cancer subtypes poverty
insurance so those are all factors that
we're also looking at and we're doing
that through a couple of training grants
that we have Luke Duke so a lot of to
you a little bit about those so we have
a p20 grant from NCI for our cancer
disparities translational research
partnership so this is with Duke so we
have a couple of pilot projects
including one on IBC but I really want
to emphasize that we have this cancer
research education program that educates
our PhD students on bio banking and
clinical trial accrue as it relates to
underrepresented minorities and then the
second program is we have a grant from
komen on a graduate training in
disparities research program and again
this is this has a focus on getting our
PhD students out of the lab
and into the community where they can
focus on community-based participatory
research they're really helping them
connect what they do in the lab to what
happens with the patient what happens
with a community so so our trainees meet
with patient advocates they learn about
human subjects research our beat
protocols they've been working on design
in surveys and organizing focus groups
so one of those was an ABC listening
forum that they hosted that the women's
health awareness day on campus back in
April so that's what we had 50 women
come in and we got some sense of whether
they heard about IBC before what they
knew about it so that that's an ongoing
project where we're now gonna go out to
focus groups and start building an
education campaign around inflammatory
breast cancer so to the research I was
going to talk about today so the first
one is to look at mechanisms of
therapeutic resistance at IBC so again
this was a collaboration with dr. dairy
at Duke where their lab has generated a
resistance model for ABC so he did that
by taking a breast cancer cell line
inflammatory breast cancer cell line
some 149 which is one of the few
available cell lines that we can use for
ABC and then she did chronic well the
pattern of exposure so culture those
cells in the presence of the patented
drug for a few weeks and you end up
selecting out a drug-resistant clonal
population which we term are someone for
unite or resistant someone for you know
it's so those cells are resistant to a
patented they grew and l'p and even
survived so they've adapted
then we also went on to develop a cell
line where if we remove the drug from
the resistant cell iron within about two
months we can select a clone of
population that regains sensitively to
well apparently there are some 149 or a
reverse resistant someone for you and so
they regain sensitivity and
in the presence of without it so that's
what I'm Manos I'm going to talk about
today and here's just a snapshot of cell
proliferation data so on the y-axis is
cell proliferation percent on the x-axis
is a dose response for the drug
lapatinib so if you look at some 149 to
begin a nice thirst response in response
to a pattern F so they're being
inhibited by that drug whereas they
reverse the resistance some 149 s there
in purple as the Platinum has no effect
on that cell light and again the reverse
resistance we see a nice those response
bad episode just here and differences in
drug sensitivity there so we're
interested in looking at how do these
different cell lines respond to other
drugs upper tyrosine kinase inhibitors
so what all allows us to do that at our
Institute is that we have a
high-throughput screening iContact core
essentially a small drug discovery
company based based in our based in
their institution so we have at our
disposal over 500,000 small molecules
stored on site so these include
fda-approved drugs commercial drugs
proprietary drugs and then we have
automation of database systems allow us
to screen large numbers of drugs against
large numbers of cell lines and then we
have the faculty and staff expertise
from industry we do medicinal chemistry
we collaborations always interested in
collaborations so please email me if
you're interested and we've started a
couple of small start-up companies so
one of the drug libraries we wanted the
screen on these cell lines is the NCI on
collar approved oncology drug library so
this consists of 89 drugs at the time
that we got from the developmental
therapeutics program NCI and then we we
sort of group those by mechanism or type
of drugs in there on the left so we want
to screen those 89 drugs induce respond
against parental resistant and reverse
resistant some 149 cells so here I'm
just showing a heatmap readout for some
149 resistant someone for you know it
cells so again this is cell
proliferation data with dosing the drug
or a 10-point at this range green means
at 0% inhibition red means there's a hug
percent and I've got I know it's a
little difficult to read thereby got a
patent I highlighted there when we see
that it's sensitive to the someone for
need irons but has no effect really on
the resistant so what was interesting
about this profiling of these drugs was
that we saw a group of drugs which has
shown they're clustered at the top by
that bracket that so they had cross
resistance so there's a set of drugs
that are also resistant in there is a
resistance some 149 so that was a group
of targeted and key mates therapeutic
drugs so it wasn't just a lot patent
alone that share resistance in that cell
line so that was that was sort of
interesting to us so if you plot I see
50 values for the parental or some 114
irons and the resistance some 149 so
these are some of the drugs show
dramatic differences between those two
cell lines we see big increases in I see
50 inhibitory concentration value 50%
inhibition for drugs they include
chemotherapeutic agents and also
tyrosine kinase and evidence so maybe
about it does internal when we see this
sort of cross resistant phenotype so if
we then go on and also add in our
reverse resistance some 149 cell lines
again if you look at the top there
around the bracket we see that those
cells regain or reset attires to all of
those targeted and chemotherapeutic
drugs that are resistant in the ass at
one forty nights so we go from sensitive
to resistant to sensitive for that
collection of compounds and again if you
look at I see 50 values between those
three isagenix cell
you see again the ic50 value goes up for
a resistant but then comes back down for
the reverse resistant as they regain
sensitivity to each of those drugs so
again this was sort of unexpected and
interesting to us as I said you know
their chemotherapy agents they're the
retired
tyrosine kinase inhibitors so they are
very diverse mechanisms of action but if
you read a bit more about them they are
all reported to induce reactive oxygen
species or RR s so we started delving a
bit more into that area so oxidative
stress and redox adaptation cancer so
oxidative stress is an imbalance between
our s and the psalms ability to remove
our air so it's antioxidant defenses so
chronic exposure to increased RS
stimulates protective mechanisms or a
redox adaptation so that promotes
therapeutic resistance so essentially
oxidative stress acts as a selective
pressure to promote the survival cells
that can detoxify the increased ro s so
we looked at some of these mechanisms in
our cell lines
so one thing we wanted to measure was ro
s production so on the left there I'm
sharing an assay that we used to measure
our RS so percent cells where RR s
staining is on the y axis so in the
white bars there the parental some 140
diets so you can see that if you put a
little pad name on those cells which is
showing with a plus lock there you see a
big increase in our RS however if you
put lapatinib on the resistance someone
for Nino ends that's the black bar you
do not see that increase in RS so
somehow they've adapted if you look at
the reverse resistance some 149 s in the
gray bar after a couple of months they
have also regained their sensitivity so
about him when you see a big increase in
RS when you treat those cells with the
path
so part of that is to also look at
expression of antioxidant proteins soak
a delays and superoxide dismutase so we
see that blue for those proteins are
increased in the resistance some 149 and
decrease back down in the reverse
resistance to levels seen with the
parental cells so that's some western
blot data we also did some more western
blot data to look at some people tonic
pathways so we see activation of pro
survival stress response sickling in the
resistance some 149 so if you look at
the Western blot there we see that XA a
P and I APs and survived in all increase
in the resistant some 149 compared to
the parental and then there those levels
are decreased back down in the reverse
resistance so those proteins are all
part of the ER inhibitor of apoptosis
pathway so what do we thinks going on so
we think that our are some 149 sellers
are cross resistant to those drugs due
to their suppression of the oxidative
stress response so those resistance some
149 Zev adapt adapt redox adaptation
they've increased antioxidant capacity
they've increased survival factors so
those cells can survive in the presence
of the drug they do not die whereas the
reverse resistant cells they decreased
survival factors they decreased
antioxidants so when we add drug to
those cells we see big increases in our
RS and subsequent cell deaths so you
know you know we're interesting on that
whether cells come from weather
resistant cells come from so we and
others have proposed that there's a
subpopulation of reversibly drug
tolerance cells that a dormant until
they see drug or see high concentrations
of drugs so is a subset that tolerate
growing in the presence
the drug indefinitely and we call these
drug-tolerant persistence so if you look
at the schematic in the upper right
there on the left is essentially the
parental with some 149 cells that have
both sensitive cells and drug-tolerant
persistent cells and if you expose
that's so heterogeneity heterogeneity to
a tiki art I like the patent here we see
only the drug-tolerant cells emerge and
survive so the suggestion is that these
drugs on our clones exist they know
though that may share some properties
with cancer stem cells and someone from
United sellers do show significant ALDH
positivity a marker for cancer stem
cells and we see even higher increase in
ALDH in the resistance at one forty
nights close so we're investigating a
lot of these mechanisms here the role of
cancer stem cells drug-tolerant
persisters and that's an ongoing project
but and happy to share more about that
if you have questions so to get to the
second part of the seminar so this is
targeting the hedgehog pathway in
inflammatory breast cancer so the
hedgehog pathway has a central role in
the growth of a vast array of cancers on
the left here it's sharing all the
cancers that have had a role the
Hedgehog has a role in in that cancer
and on the right is a yes schematic of
the Hedgehog signaling so the Hedgehog
ligand binds to the patched receptor and
relieves inhibition of the smoothin
receptor then Glee transcription factors
are activated and translocating to the
nucleus internal various transcriptional
programs so there are drugs that are on
the market that target smoothened and
hibbott Hedgehog signaling so those are
essentially out there for basal cell
carcinoma but again acquired resistance
is seen your patients taking these
smoothing directed drugs so another
Challenge so my lab is interested in
Glee one activation of breast cancer so
Glee one is one of those downstream
effectors of Hedgehog signaling and as
there's a lot of evidence out there now
that flea one has a critical role in the
progression and invasiveness of multiple
capsules so Glee one promotes an
aggressive breast cancer phenotype
nuclear expression glee one is a strong
predictor of poor prognosis in many
cancers including breast cancer and Glee
one expression correlates with poor
survival and breast cancer patients
especially with the basal subtype so on
the on the right there is some survival
data from patients who I ever have the
lugli one expression or high Glee one
expression and those are patients with
basal-like breast cancer so we've looked
at Glee one expression in many cell
lines here I'm just showing a set of
breast cancer cell lines we don't
qrt-pcr to look at messenger RNA
expression fleet one and what we see
across this panel of cell lines is that
Glee one is highly expressed in basal
like ABC and basal like non IBC breast
cancer cell lines we've also shown
previously that if we knock down Glee
one in someone for ourselves as a
reduction in cell proliferation so how
is Glee one activated it's activated by
both canonical and non-canonical
mechanisms so canonical is through the
Hedgehog smooth and pathway that I just
showed you in that earlier slide there's
also quite a lot of literature now that
other pathways can activate FLE one
through what's turn non canonical
mechanisms and indeed there's a few
papers out there now are showing that
Glee one activation of breast cancer
saralidze is predominantly Hedgehog
smooth and independent so non canonical
and we've shown that for IVC where those
so is about edged up responsive so sorry
most breast cancer cell lines it seems
that there's a non canonic
activation we published some of that
back in 2011 so for a number of reasons
we're looking at targeting at the level
of Glee 1 so downstream off smoothened
there's a lot of interesting developing
Glee inhibitors that would both inhibit
canonical and non-canonical mechanisms
so we're interested in looking at Glee
antagonists that block the activation
and there are a number of Glee
antagonists that have been identified
from Glee luciferase reporter screens so
the HPI is shown here
block Glee activation they can block the
1 translocation to the nucleus
JK 184 acts in the nucleus the block Li
mediated transcription against like and
58 and Kent 61 acts in the nucleus the
block V 1 as well excuse me so so we we
did a study where we wanted a profile
set of these Glee antagonists in
multiple models of IBC so this is just
really a snapshot of quite a lot of data
from one of my PhD students so in the
upper left panel there we assayed all
these inhibitors in thirst response in a
hedgehog functional cell-based assay and
we saw that they all in hibbity hedgehog
Stirling signaling to varying degrees we
then took a subset of those compounds
and they're in inhibition of
proliferation in the panel at breast
cancer cell lines we looked at how those
drugs could inhibit colony formation of
breast cancer cell lines and three of
those how were reasonably potent in that
model we looked out at a couple of those
drugs and 61 at GK or 184 that had
dramatic effects on flee transcriptional
targets and cell cycle progression genes
so you know we were trying to sort of
triage out what were the most effective
or efficacious Glee antagonists that we
went
in animal models so we also looked at
Glee antagonists in a high-throughput 3d
sphere model so this is where the cells
are growing experience that we think is
more representative of a tumor and more
predictive of in vivo efficacy so we
have a format where we take 384 well
plates are ultra low attachment we can
seed cells in each well and we get a
single spheroid that forms in each of
those wells we can then use high content
imaging to look at various effects of
drugs on spheroid formation so the upper
panel there is just a shot of one of the
384 well plates or part of it where
we've done it dose response of two
elusively antagonists gku 184 and Gantt
61 we've got a dose response we were
running them in replicates of 5 we're
looking at effects on spirit area spirit
fragmentation just below that is zooming
in on those steroids after they've been
stained with Hoechst a new year one that
sustained a hurricane's with DNA here
one stains ourselves if they are dead it
can only get into a cell if it's dead so
so we can image those spheroids that
different drug concentrations at
different effects of different drugs and
as I said some drugs shrink spirits some
drugs that are fragmented spirits so
we're using various analytical methods
to analyze those effects so we can
quantitate some of those effects for
example at the bottom there I'm sharing
a couple of graphs so one is looking at
sphere area after we dose on you can't
61 we can generate an IC 50 for that
drug in terms of Herot effects for an
area on the right panel their effects on
spirit year 1 so we see an increase
above a certain concentration where we
see that the year the cell is a die so
we can generate a lot of data on a lot
of compounds in the in this model
and we've also developed so along with
Debbie a tumor emboli high-throughput
tumor in my model so I mentioned when I
was talking about IBC that the presence
of tumor emboli a hallmark of ABC so we
developed a model where we can grew some
149 cells as essentially tumor in ballet
and then we can put drugs on on those
models and see effects for example if we
treat those tumor in below Afghans 61 we
see a dramatic decrease in the size of
the tumor and blight so that's shown in
the images there on the right
so all this data really told us that
game 61 in particular was a very
interesting drug that was a Glee
antagonist they had dramatic effects in
our panel of phenotypic assays very IVC
so we took that drug in vivo in a mouse
model so we had a mouse where we put
some 149 cells in the memory pad of the
mouse so it's an orthotopic model the
tumor grows and then we start treating
with either vehicle or Gantz 61 dosing
every few days and measuring the size of
the tumor every few days so on the upper
left panel there I'm showing some 149
tumor progression in that mouse model
where on the y axis is 2 volume as it's
increasing as the tumor is growing and
the x axis is their number of weeks of
treatment so you can see that if we dose
the mice with gang 61 we get a
significant decrease in the size of the
tumors and that's shown in the picture
below we also see dramatic effects on
Glee one protein expression and glue on
the messenger RNA expression so again
get 61 was having a dramatic effect in
this in vivo model so it looks like it's
a promising compound so what also is
interesting about against 61 is it it's
been shown to by
and directly to Glee one protein so
there's a few publications down there in
the bottom right and so here I'm sharing
a schematic of Glee one it's a large
protein it's 1106 amino acids over a
hundred thousand molecular weight
insides so the zinc finger of ZF domains
are shown there at Brown on schematic so
like I said it's recently been shown
again sixty-one binds directly to the
zinc finger domain in particular the
zinc thing of one and the same finger
too so you know we're interested in this
mechanism we're interested in seeing if
targeting the zinc fingers ugly one is a
viable strategy for moving forward so
yeah so our lab is interested in clear
arm we're looking at multiple strategies
for developing small molecules that will
target clear one and it is a challenge
to find drugs that target transcription
factors that's why it's unusual can 61
bones directly ugly one transcript
transcription factors typically do not
have what we call druggable sites they
don't have nice pockets where we can get
a small moniker in there that are binds
tightly so you can take some of
alternative approaches so we can look at
blocking DNA binding some of what we're
doing we can't 61 we can also look at
blocking nuclear translocation of blue
one and we can also look at inhibiting
activating kinase it's that are a number
of cases that a phosphorylated lee one
to activate it so again we could target
those kinase is enhanced target clear
one activation so one of those counties
is that we're interested in is dy rq-180
or dual specificity tyrosine regulated
kinase 1a there's been a number of
publications out there showing that this
kinase promotes nuclear localization of
glee one and stimulates lee one
dependent transcriptional activity so on
the left panel there is some data from
one of the publications below where
leave
taken h.323 cells excuse me
and they transfect in a Glee worm GFP
reporter and flee one remains in the
cytoplasm if they then COO transfecting
dy rk1 a kinase likely one then moves to
the nucleus if you in if you take a dy
okay when a construct that's kinase then
so as their activity clean one stays in
the cytoplasm so it's pretty strong
evidence that dy our k18 is promoting
glee one nuclear translocation so we
were interested in that for sure
so one thing we were interested in was
whereabouts on Glee one as I said that's
a very large proteins as dy rk1 a
phosphor ly clear what so one of those
publications had showing that Glee one
was phosphorylated but it was in two
reasonably large fragments they didn't
really narrow it out whereabouts that
phosphorylation event was so we were
interested in in identifying that
phosphorylation site we were going to do
it using phosphate a mapping and mass
spectrometry and that's a collaboration
we did with dr. Lee graves at UNC Chapel
Hill and this was work done by been a
who's a student in my lab the reason she
did this using an in vitro kinase assay
so we incubate Tilly one protein with dy
rk1 a protein in the absence of presence
of ATP in the absence of presence of a
dy rk1 a inhibitor called harming so
incubate those we then run them on an
SDS page gel we cut out the band's ugly
one so that's shown in the black boxes
there and do triptych digest at the
protein in that band we enriched for
phosphorus and we do mass spec so on the
right is showing a mass spectrum of in
the absence of ATP and in the presence
and we see a shift in molecular weight
that corresponds to a phosphorylation of
that and when we look at our sample as
we see that phosphorylation events only
occur in sample 3 that's highlighted
there with a red circle so that's the
sample where we have 3 1 plus D way okay
what a plus ATP so that's not unexpected
but what we did see we only saw one
sequence that was phosphorylate so that
was interesting so serene 408 it was the
only phosphorylation site we saw that
was phosphorylated by dy r k1 so if we
look at that phospho cerium 4r8
it falls within the putative nuclear
localization sequence of glia well so
that sort of makes some sense that dy
Kewanee is phosphorylated at site within
the NOS and hence was has a role of
impact on the function of Glee while
inherit by translate key into the
nucleus so we have obviously ongoing
studies looking at mutating that so if
we mutate that phosphorus serine site to
another amino acid does that then
broccoli one translocation that would be
our prediction so you know as a you know
a lab as a big interesting drug
discovery for the hedgehog pathway so
we're interested in seeing if we could
target dyr k1a with small molecules to
blockly one activity so can we find an
inhibitor maybe you have a very
selective chemical pro to block the
pathway and potentially turn it into a
drunk long-term so you know our
hypothesis is we have an inhibitor Tyr
k1 a that blocks 3-1 translocations
nucleus that hence blocks li one
activation so we've developed a
high-throughput screening assay for this
kinase so this consists of purified
enzymes and we're using what's term TR
Frank
so the dyr k18 kinase has a GST tag
glutathione as transfer is tagged and we
have an antibody to the GST that is
European licked
we then have a tracer that binds in the
ATP binding pocket of the kinase that
are shown on the schematic there on the
right so in that in that condition
the tracer and the European are in close
proximity and you get high fret you get
a strong signal if you inhibit the
kinase or you have a drug that blocks
theresa binding to the kinase you don't
have that close proximity of the Teresa
and the European there's a low fret so
that's inefficient so that's essentially
how that asset works that's where the
window is so we've run a number of
screens on dyr k1a i'm just showing a
little bit of that data so one of the
high throughput screens we did was using
a fda-approved drug collection of 1200
the compounds that's termed preswick so
we screen each of those compounds at a
single 10 micro molar concentration so
each one has one drug and it's just a 10
lakh robot
so on the right there at the bottom is a
typical high throughput screening
scanner plot that we used to look at the
data so on the y-axis is inhibition of
the kinase activity on the x-axis is the
number of well so each well is a
different compound so in the red and
blue we have our controls the red are
our 0% inhibition controls the blue are
our 100% inhibition controls we have
those controls on every plate obviously
and then the green the green circles are
each compound that we've screened so if
we take a cut-off of 50% inhibition so
anything about 50% we term an inhibitor
we see that there are 23 compounds with
greater than 50% efficient so we've
confirmed those by dose response and
we're we're looking at running those in
a number of assays to see if they've got
potential as inhibitors of pathway
inhibitors the activation evidence so
just to finish up we've taken a number
of strategies to target
liwon we've shown that people yrk when a
fossil basically one within the nuclear
localization sequence we've identified
some inhibitors that target dyr k1a
we're also looking at Kent 61 still when
its role in blocking zinc finger DNA
binding and again as a potential drug
so really summary from the Hedgehog part
of my talk we've shown a Glee one it's
highly expressed in basal-like breast
cancers including the IPC against 61 at
DirectBuy an ugly one as activity
multiple IPC models and activity in vivo
so we're currently running studies that
target novel mechanisms of Glee one
activation and as I said we're testing
our dy our kya inhibitors and the number
of cellular and in beaver models hoping
to publish some of that data too so I'm
just gonna finish up acknowledge a
number of people in my lab that mike
marina helen the Shalonda and
collaborators dr. Debbie and dr. graves
Dave dark sea and also funding from DoD
the NCI and the Susan G Komen Foundation
and as I said we work very closely with
patient advocates from a number of IBC
foundations so Ginny Mason at IBC
Research Foundation so I'm going to
finish there thank you and any questions
thank you dr. Williams for that
informative presentation we will now
serve the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask for
used to be so now just click on the ask
a question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email now let's get started our first
question is what strategy could you take
to eliminate the emergence of drug
intolerant cells yeah so that's that's a
good question so I think we showed that
in those drug-tolerant cells are out
resistant someone 14 owns that there's
increases in survival pathways as
increases in those and type taluk
pathways so you know we're interested in
maybe looking at drugs that block those
pathways so we think that if we treat
the parental cells with a pad nib in
combination with drugs that target that
those redox adaptation pathways we can
eliminate the emergence of those
drug-tolerant clearance so we need to do
some sort of combination here where we
knock out you know the sensitive cells
and also a knock out there's tolerance
elves at the sector
Thanks and there's Ghent 61 a viable
drug Canada again that's a good question
there's a very recent paper showing that
the active form account 61 is actually a
fragment of the structure I showed in
that earlier slide so we're still
looking at it from a but this is a
chemistry point of view there's not been
a lot of data have done preclinically on
gang 61 so you know the typical sort of
toxicology study I haven't seen anything
published on seal activity of that
compound so it's I think that's still
still an open question Thanks
and for our last question are you
concerned about selectivity of your dyr
k1a inhibitors huh
again that's a good question you know
there are Chinese inhibitors I've been
fda-approved that have bearing seal
activities some of them here multiple
kinase is some reasonably selective we
think we might need a reasonably
selective dyr ky1 a inhibitor there are
some very closely related kinases as the
YK won't be 2 3 or 4
there are co-pays or which are another
kinase family very closely related so we
try to understand how much selectivity
we need do we need to have something
that's absolutely selective dy okay when
an inhibitor or if it's sort of pan dy
RK inhibitor is that sufficient so
that's that's part of our ongoing
ongoing studies Thanks well I'd like to
once again thank dr. Williams for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January of 2019
we will receive an email from laberd's
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye